all right so last week chris sims listed
his top 10 receivers
missing from that collection of players
keenan allen of the los angeles chargers
and allen has complained about being
omitted from chris's list specifically
but that has spawned
a back and forth between allen and one
of the top receivers currently in the
nfl mike evans said keenan allen i'm
tired of biting my tongue
tyree kill mike evans chris godwin the
list goes on are not better than me
faster than me
every day of the week but separation
child please mike evans who never says
anything
said this you tagged the wrong chris
godwin lol and don't be mad at us we
didn't make the rankings or care about
them i like the confidence but be
realistic
you're not on my level bro
i think that's the the harshest most
combative thing mike evans has ever said
in his life chris but see what you
started i know proud of yourself
that's what i do i know and no i'm not
proud of myself because i like these
guys like i like keena now and i know
these guys are gonna like kind of hold
it against me personally uh but this is
what i do it's part of my job it's hey
it's part of driving conversation for
football all right and uh yeah brandon
stokley used to call me the uh
you know i used to stir the pot and he
used the bad word the crap stir he used
the other word right that's what you've
been calling what you mean you know what
i mean gotcha why wasn't why wasn't
keenan allen number 10 in your top 10. i
like keenan allen but keena and allen's
got to be in certain offenses in certain
offenses in football keenan allen
wouldn't be able to just thrive or
succeed he's got to be in an offense
that really knows how to utilize the
slot receiver and that's why i just
can't put him on the list of some of
these other guys let alone when he
catches the ball he is not capable of
doing what a lot of these guys on this
list are capable of doing you know i
really like him he was right there on
the edge with devonte adams and jarvis
landry and dj moore of guys that i was
like man i gotta put them in the top ten
how am i gonna leave them out you know
it was not easy but let me just set this
straight he ain't as good as mike evans
that's insane i mean mike evans is a
rare rare talent to come in football and
so is tyree kill you know tyree kill
again this is where i'll challenge
people it might not be the most
challenged you know polished receiver
you've ever seen and i didn't get to
rebuttal rodney harrison last week when
he kind of said he didn't think he was
number one i've never seen bill
belichick cover any receiver in the
history of his life the way he's had to
cover tyree kill that to me just says it
all he played defenses against kansas
city that he's never played in his
career and he did him play after play
after play because of tyree kill so that
just shows you the effect of what he has
and so to me i don't care that he might
not be able to run the best out route or
slant route like a some of the other
receivers it doesn't matter defenses are
changing their game plans more than ever
with tyree kill on the field compared to
the other guys and to me that says top
receiver keenan allen really awesome but
not a difference maker that way sorry
i personally think to be a top 10
receiver you have to have that kind of
game breaking speed right that forces a
defense to to account for you with more
than one man that that's the price of
admission if you don't come to the table
with that you're not a top 10 receiver
you can get open you can make catches
that's great but to be in the top 10 you
have to be the red dot guy you have to
be the guy that when they are sitting
down to figure out how in the hell
they're going to slow down this offense
job number one is how do we cover
this guy how do we deal with this guy
and i think all of your top 10 receivers
pass that test chris that's what you
have to have uh be a top 10 receipt i
agree no disrespect to keenan allen
though he doesn't have the speed if you
don't have the speed you can't be a top
guy right you know there's a certain
offenses like you know i always kind of
revert back to seattle in this type of
situation like seattle doesn't use the
slot receiver
they would ask you they would be you
need to be a physical beast a little bit
to get open in seattle he would he would
not be the same keenan allen we know if
he had to play in a system like that or
other ones that are similar to that in
football where they don't have a million
tricks through great offensive game plan
design like the sean payton's or some of
the guys that have been there and and
with the chargers who have had a pretty
damn awesome offense for a lot of years
they just don't know how to utilize all
those all the time so yes you know i
look at guys like a tyree kill or mike
evans and just go i don't give a damn if
you put them in a second grade offense
on an nfl team they're gonna dominate
games because they're that special of a
talent and there's other guys that are
not on this list who are complaining
where i go no
it's the system you're quarterback
you're good man but you're not what you
think you are but there's a lot of
talented receivers in football and it's
a good discussion
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports